es nimmt kein ende oder ist das das ende
der internationalen raumstation iss
schon wieder wurden neue risse in der ss
aufgespürt diesmal im russischen modul
sarja dem ersten ass ass modul überhaupt
die pannenserie der raumstation geht
also weiter ist der katastrophale
zustand der raumstation überhaupt noch
in den griff zu bekommen und welche
pläne gibt es für die zukunft der als es
eine premiere gibt es auf jeden fall
noch dieses jahr und zwar für den
deutschen astronaut matthias maurer
klicks und science in future geht es
dreimal pro woche spannende science sie
das abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los ganz
herzlich willkommen immer wieder sorgen
die lecks in der hülle der
internationalen raumstation iss für
aufregung keine frage die raumstation
iss alt und ihr zustand verschlechtert
sich immer weiter seit einigen monaten
macht ein russisches modul probleme denn
es weist lecks auf und jetzt wurden auch
noch weitere risse aufgespürt und zwar
an einer anderen einheit die zu den
ältesten der station gehört immer mehr
fachleute warnen davor dass die
situation nicht mehr in den griff zu
bekommen ist was weiß man bisher über
die risse und die lecks besteht gefahr
für die besatzung und wie wird es mit
dem außenposten der menschheit
weitergehen die antworten auf all diese
fragen gibt es hier bei pixum future
dass die internationale raumstation iss
immer wieder mit problemen zu kämpfen
hat ist kein wunder denn das muss man
sich mal vorstellen einige module wurden
bereits vor rund 30 jahren produziert
noch zu sowjetzeiten ein paar jahre
vorher hatte der personal computer erst
seinen siegeszug begonnen und damals war
man nicht von einem langzeitaufenthalt
im all ausgegangen laut plan sollten
diese module maximal 15 jahre im einsatz
sein hinzu kommt die iss war zur zeit
ihrer entstehung übrigens gar nicht
wirklich als eine wissenschafts station
gedacht damals ging es um eine reine
machtdemonstration von seiten des
westens ihre entstehung hatte damit also
sogar eine politische wirkung aus ihr
wurde dann ein symbol für das ende des
kalten krieges denn geplant wurde sie
dann in den 80er jahren doch als
gemeinsames projekt von ost und west
dementsprechend ist die ice es auch
aufgebaut der innenraum so groß wie ein
jumbo jet ihre fläche vergleichbar mit
einem fußballfeld und zudem gigantische
420 tonnen schwer wenn man ganz ehrlich
ist brachten diese dimensionen aber nur
nachteile zu unflexibel zu groß und
unfassbar teuer ihre ganze organisation
nahm ordentlich zeit in anspruch viele
dinge wurden zu bürokratisch angegangen
viel zu langsam und schwerfällig wurden
aufgrund der dann doch schweren
konflikte zwischen den beteiligten
partnern auf der erde wichtige
entscheidungen getroffen und das dauerte
deshalb mitunter ziemlich lang bis
experimente tatsächlich durchgeführt
werden konnten vergingen zum teil sieben
und mehr jahre ende november 1998 dann
flog das erste modul der iss in die
erdumlaufbahn weitere zwölf jahre und
insgesamt 42 flüge folgten damit alle
bauteile für die raumstation ins all
gebracht werden konnten seit 21 jahren
also seit dem jahr 2000 leben und
arbeiten raumfahrer und raum fahren dort
und das hat bei vielen für begeisterung
gesorgt so zum beispiel auch beim
deutschen raumfahrer alexander gerst er
hatte vor drei jahren 2018 von da ss
getwittert die komplexeste wertvollste
und unwahrscheinlichste maschine die die
menschheit jemals gebaut hat zum wohle
aller doch mittlerweile ist die iss in
die jahre gekommen immer wieder kommt es
zum problem wir berichten hier bei pixum
20 user regelmäßig darüber erst vor
kurzem hatte es schwierigkeiten bei
einem unlock vorgang eines neuen
russischen forschungsmoduls gegeben ende
juli 2021 hatte das russische modul
locker die iss erreicht um zunächst war
alles glatt gegangen doch dann fingen
die probleme an das modul hatte erneut
die triebwerke aktiviert obwohl es fest
mit der iss verbunden war und das ohne
jegliche vorwarnung die gesamte station
drehte sich dadurch mehr als einmal um
die eigene achse weitere russische
triebwerke die sich automatisch
aktiviert hatten stellten sich mit
voller kraft dagegen luca war vom boden
nicht zu erreichen ein ehemaliger nasa
mitarbeiter hatte das ganze scharf
kritisiert das muss man sich mal
vorstellen was da oben los gewesen sein
muss als dieses ungetüm sich mehrmals
gedreht hat ich kann mir vorstellen
dem einen oder anderen war da wirklich
nicht wohl nun treten weitere probleme
auf bei einer kontrolle haben russische
kosmonauten und risse im modul sarja
gefunden der chefingenieur des
russischen raumfahrtunternehmens
roskosmos wladimir solowjow meinte dass
der fund nichts gutes bedeutet er geht
davon aus das zitat die risse sich mit
der zeit ausbreiten werden zudem
verweist er auf frühere warnungen
ausgesprochen hatte demnach könnte die
alternde technik da ss nach 2025 eine
wahre lawine an defekten auslösen noch
habe man glück da durch die
oberflächlichen risse noch kein luft
entweiche doch möglicherweise ist das
nur noch eine frage der zeit seiner
meinung nach sind die systeme des
russischen eis es segments zitat in
hohem maße verschlissen zuvor hatte man
monatelang mit dem schwestermodell
gekämpft bereits im vergangenen herbst
hatte sich das team der iss einen
teebeutel zunutze gemacht um die
undichte stelle ausfindig zu machen denn
der teebeutel bewegt sich in der
schwerelosigkeit auf die undichte stelle
zu und tatsächlich in einem übergangs
teil des western moduls konnten die
kosmonauten mit diesem trick einen
viereinhalb zentimeter langen riss
identifizieren der dann gestopft wurde
doch das problem war damit nicht behoben
und es trat weiter luft aus dem november
folgte dann ein außeneinsatz im weltall
doch trotz intensiver suche wurde man
auch hier nicht fündig russlands
raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos hielt sich
lange bedeckt und beschwichtigte immer
wieder wurde betont dass es keine
unmittelbare gefahr für die besatzung
auf der es es gebe doch mittlerweile
werden auch andere stimmen laut
fachleute weltweit sind sich sicher dass
es mit der ss zu ende geht im
vergangenen herbst hatte sich dazu auch
der russische kosmonaut gennadi padalka
geäußert der mit
878 tagen den rekord für die längste
flugdauer im all heldt in einem
interview sagt er ganz offen alle module
des russischen teils sind abgenutzt auch
in russland selbst gibt es warnung dass
sich der zustand der ice es immer weiter
verschlechtert im frühjahr diesen jahres
2021 wurde dann aus regierungskreisen
eine technische inspektion angekündigt
um auf dessen basis über die weitere
beteiligung an der iss zu entscheiden
die entweichende luft und damit auch der
sauerstoff der so weniger wird deuten
manche als zeigt so auch der chef der
russischen raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos
dimitri rogosin demnach gehe es mit der
iss zu ende es ist zeit für mich in
rente zu gehen und damit meint er nicht
sich selbst sondern die raumstation er
hofft aber dass die station noch einige
jahre bis 2024 oder möglicherweise sogar
bis 2028 durchhalten wird doch
wahrscheinlich ist dass russland sich
bereits 2025 aus dem internationalen
gemeinschaftsprojekt zurückziehen wird
das wurde so immer wieder mal angedeutet
die russische weltraumagentur roskosmos
hatte in erwägung gezogen module
abzubauen und diese dann für eine neue
raumstation zu verwenden die us
regierung dagegen überlegt den betrieb
des nasa teils privatisieren zu lassen
in kooperation mit privaten raumfahrt
unter den wie etwas basics könnten so
immer mal wieder weltraumtouristen zur
iss fliegen die nasa möchte bis zum jahr
2028 astronauten und astronauten an bord
der station arbeiten lassen und so gab
es erst vor einigen tagen nachschub mit
der hilfe einer falcon 9 rakete von
spacex wurde eis avocados ameisen und
einige materialien für experimente des
deutschen astronaut matthias maurer auf
die iss gebracht denn er wird der
nächste deutsche im weltall sein der
vierte deutsche überhaupt auf der iss am
31 oktober soll der staat mit einer
space extrakte und der crew dragon
kapsel des raumfahrtunternehmens
erfolgen als erster deutscher überhaupt
denn sein vorgänger alexander gerst war
noch mit einer russischen sojus
hingeflogen dazu matthias maurer ich
freue mich natürlich sehr dass es
endlich losgehen würde ich arbeite schon
einige jahre darauf hin endlich in den
weltraum zu fliegen und glaube dass ich
erst aufgeregt sein werde wenn ich
wirklich auf der startrampe in der
kapsel sitze sechs monate lang soll
maurer auf der iss forschen und leben
und unter anderem experimente von
alexander gerst fortführen konkret geht
es um die entstehung von planeten im
universum und die schwerelosigkeit die
mithilfe eines staub experiments
untersucht werden soll die ameisen die
jetzt zur iss gebracht wurden sind
ebenfalls teil eines experiments zum
thema schwerelosigkeit sein aufenthalt
auf der ss fällt also in eine zeit der
ungewissheit wie geht es mit dem
außenposten der menschheit in zukunft
weiter ist möglicherweise eine
kommerzialisierung eine
zukunftsperspektive für die iss während
maurers mission soll es zwei besuche von
weltraum touristen geben falls es dann
zu ende geht käme übrigens ein
kontrollierter absturz ins meer in frage
denn fest steht die länge der ice es von
mehr als 100 metern erlaubt ist auf dem
gang ein fall dass die station als
weltraumschrott durch das all fliegt und
sie ist so groß dass sie in keinem fall
verglühen kann als absturzort kommt also
nur der pazifik mit seinem friedhof der
raumschiffe in frage denn nur dort kann
man gefahrlos raumschiffe abstürzen
lassen internationale raumstation iss
vor dem aus sein stoff wird knapp
anklicken anschauen und auf jeden fall
abonnieren den abo button gibt es unter
jedem video oder hier kostet nichts und
macht schlau bis dann bleibt dran